thank you and thank you for the
invitation in case you wonder me the way
my talk has not much to do with
robustness and some with high
dimensional statistics let me start with
a very basic where it's not really clear
there is a high dimensional tissue at
all and before I go on let me say that
those are my collaborators on some of
those projects I'm gonna present today
and I'm gonna start with Euclidean the
matrix distance matrix completion
so the problem goes as follows if you
have an under undirected graph G with
vertex set V and in the edge set E in
assume V is going to be finite and can
be want to end we are lost on the arathi
Delta I just got the note the
dissimilarity between nodes I MJ and
it's only available as usual when I and
J form an edge in the graph okay so we
say that D with coefficients D IJ is you
can disturb matrix if there are there is
a configuration of points in some
Euclidean space such that D IJ is equal
to the norm so the UK and distance
between y I and YJ and we only require
actually
okay this is fine okay
and so the problem at least you know
from generally speaking of completing so
you can distance metric completion is
following you're given a weight graph
which actually dictates what distances
are available to you through the edge
set E and then the problem is to find
the you can't distance matrix D such
that it's coefficient this will be
parceled e to be consistent with where
have you close to the so whoever you
observing you want the matrix to be to
have to be close to that
okay so for example be formalized say an
optimization framework it's like to
solve say the year so minimize error sum
of squares of course over what you
observe this is just one possible
formula okay a rephrasing of this
problem is in terms of graph embedding
so instead of talking about this as
matrices you can talk about
configuration of configurations of
points and the problem is as follows
you're given a weighted graph and this
time if I want to also be given a
desired embedding dimension D and the
plan becomes to find a configuration of
points in the chiyan space such that
they are pairwise Ukraine distances are
close to the similarities again over the
ones that are given to you okay and one
way to formalize this which is exactly
the same anyway I have in the previous
slide is through a set square as this
here and actually this has a name and
statistics called no metric scaling
although when it's also of interest to
do that when when the musician is over
all possible pairs meaning that would be
a case of a complete graph so this has a
bunch of so the problem itself this is
more like a methodology here the poem
itself is done under various names
multi-dimensional scaling graph drawing
graphic bedding I already used that one
you can distance matrix completions over
already uses one also graduation and
sensor organization there are important
connections non-trivial ones with the
nearest neighbor search which there's a
large literature on the topic there's
the last workshop in this program is
actually on near neighbor search in a
few weeks from now and there's also no
trigger connection to an area of
mathematics called in org which revolves
around embedding five metric spaces into
marginal Banach spaces this is what I'm
talking about now is relatively a
elementary compared to a much more
sophisticated mathematics that going to
the X in particular so that level
complexity there's a non-trivial
relationship with the literature okay so
when the graph is complete and the the
similarities are so when the one we say
that the graph is realizable meaning
there is really configuration of point
that for which the the sonorities are
the pairwise Euclidean distances then
the problem can be solved exactly via
and eigenvalue problem and as this has
been known for a long time and the
algorithm is known under the name of
classical scaling of sugar all the names
for it
so I'm just restrict myself to clean
spaces for this so I was just enjoying a
connection with Banach spaces but I
won't talk about more than that and then
that and for this one you can actually
figure out what the minimum dimension is
for exactly bedding by looking at the
essentially a spectrum of appropriate
matrix yeah so you have to be provided
with that but in practice you are
provided with that and you just embed in
that that the dimension would possibly
some error that's typically what happens
in practice so recently actually I
wanted to plug this in with Adele who
might be in the audience here also
participating in the program we finished
the paper on showing that classical
scaling is robust to noise and with
implications to for manifold learning
and some I corrected to this talk a lot
not pass directly worth mentioning okay
so that's the case for when the graph is
complete all the similarities are
available the more general case were
suddenly sorry this you noticed might be
missing is much more complicated in fact
there is an area of scenario and area of
math that's actually dedicated to a
question such as one is the graph
realizable not at all the designer T's
may not be available and you'll find
this in the name of rigidity theory okay
so for this particular case again now
it's the general case where some of the
disabilities may be missing number of
actual are golden beyond the answer the
question yes no is the graph realizable
actual methods have been suggested for
embedding the graph and try to realize
it so one of them the one I'm going to
talk about today more is based on using
graph distances to fill in the matrix of
this Unitas another one so that all of
those have been known for quite a while
so this one in particular I'm going to
say a bit more about it
and shortly it's the one that underlies
I so map the famous method for mindful
learning but in fact it was first
suggested at least as early as 1980 as a
method for you clean distance matrix
completion let me call it grab drawing
okay that's one class of methods another
one is based on for this one I really
only know two paper that really suggest
this but it's very natural is you start
by embedding a click click is a complete
sub graph so we can use classical
scaling for that and then you embed all
the other points that are that you can
by essentially what we call triangle a
short rhyolite aeration and you continue
like that ok then you call the graph and
you can show it's very very
straightforward but it's a nice idea
that you can make that work that's
pretty non row is not robust to noise
that much ok another class of techniques
so this can be derived but one goes as
follows you embed everything you can
embed so I'm particularly let's say you
embed all more possible click so all the
fixed in grabs so it might not be
competition ELISA Bowl but let's put
that aside we embed all the clicks and
for this you can use classical scaling
and then you try to is as if all the
clicks are embedded as porn sets but in
Euclidian space of same dimension as if
they're living in a parallel universes
now you have to put them together so
that you have the archery live together
in a coherent embedding up all the
points that but also of the whole graph
sorry alright so there's also direct
computation by grand descent and other
methods actually this is not the only
approach and there's another one which
consists in relaxing deployment to a
seminary program it's also a large class
of earth methods within your adilyn
Andrea's work on the topic okay so I'm
gonna focus on graph distances and what
can we do with them so this is the case
of sense of network localization which
is typically understood as being the
case where nodes in the graph are
connected if the underlying yuqian
distances assuming the graph is
realizable are below a certain threshold
okay so you observe the Souris distances
and you don't observe the other ones so
there we go so an edge here between two
points so the nodes are points of course
we don't have access to this picture all
we have is the weight matrix which is
incomplete and an edge between two
points indicates that the yukine
distance is available and I'm assuming
it's visible here okay so imagine that I
want to sorry estimate the distance
between those two points here in the red
squares so it's not directly available
right the distance between here and here
is not directly available there's no
edge between those two points in the
graph but what I do is I simply compute
the shortest path distance and record
its length and that's what that I use as
proxy for for that you can listen to
those two points so I'm using the length
of the red polygons on line here as an
estimate and as an estimate for the
length of the Purple Line okay so
everybody knows that in this audience
but this is how you define a graph
distance so remember we are given the
synergies between nodes stopped out the
node sorry several pairs of nodes and
but you can compute in principle the
distance between any pairs of nodes by
looking at the infimum of officer all
paths that connect two nodes and you for
each part to look at its length it's
really a sum of the weights along a path
and you take the infimum of all paths so
as such okay so what kind of guarantees
can we get for graph distances in terms
of estimates seen as estimates for the
underlying yuqian distances so I'm gonna
place myself in the context of a
neighborhood graph as I showed you in
the picture so only the shortest
distances are available more precisely
if xixj
are within so the X's represent the
underlying true positions let's say and
if that yukine distance between X I XJ
is less than equal to R then I'm
observing that the seniority between the
corresponding nodes in the graph I and J
and I'm given and actually given a
distance okay and this is the sort of
result that you can get this is
relatively simple to get that it was new
as far as we know so if we have a point
set as such here and we define this
quantity so this is this quantifies how
dense the point cloud is inside its
convex set so it's a convex hull okay
then if it's an here which again
quantifies density of the points inside
the convex hull is small compared to the
radius of collectivity then we have this
bound so the clean distance of course is
the shortest one so it's in geometric so
this is bound of course by the the
length of the shortest path so the graph
distance between ingénue graph no
question about that but then the upper
bound is non-trivial and you have this
error rate so it's in epsilon over R
squared okay so what's known before I'm
going to talk about it in a second
without a square but this this whole
thing is the proof is one page it's not
in completely mentoring so so yeah the
result was known before again here we
had to square so bit not as precise I
guess but this is for the Achaeans case
and what it derived was for a surface
that's a bit more in a second and it's
what this was in the context of of
proving that I so map did something
reasonable and I assume at for those
that don't know is one of the main
methods some well-known methods I don't
know if it's most popularly used in
practice but it's one of the best-known
methods for manifold learning and the
connection between manifold learning and
then graph embedding is the following in
manifold learning you're not given the
pairwise disinherited actually given
points but in high dimension okay and
you assume the points are on or near a
lower dimensional sub manifold and the
distances of interest at this one there
are long ones are not do clean distances
they're just basic distances on the
surface okay because that the ones you
want to eat actually infer to be able to
then find a chart for the manifold and
appropriate embedding at the points in
lower dimensional Euclidean space this
time okay so so you don't trust the
longest distances so if it's you know if
you have a two point R of course you
have that distance because you have the
points but if they are far away don't
trust that this is an accurate estimate
for the course point this existence
which is the case if there's some
curvature in the surface but you do
trust the shortest distances because
locally some manifold is more or less
Euclidian okay so it's as if you can
approach the manifold learning prime by
essentially looking at complete Indian
matrix sorry the distance matrix where
you actually arrays you compute all the
pairwise distances Euclidean ones but
you essentially remove all the long ones
and then try to complete it okay and if
you compete it by using rough distances
that's exactly what I saw map does
I'll come back to that so what we did in
the paper with the people of week is so
we actually revisited this and connected
with some results by do bins in robotics
in the 50s and so that we can get we
could get a similar result as Bernstein
and others got in 2004 write them up and
then we extended this to constraint
paths where we constrain the curve there
curvature so here's the setting so this
is what I just said like money for
learning the distances of interest and
other European distances but the
intrinsic distances on the underlying
surface okay and the same is true
actually and also in motion planning
where you know if you're in the domain
and you have some obstacles and you want
you know by definition don't want to go
through the obstacle you have to go
around and therefore what you're
interested in is the paths that are
intrinsic to the domain and not do you
clean that there's very largely Catriona
motion planning it is it is in a sense
can be seen as a case of this okay so so
so our target now is gonna be to
estimate the shortest path and sort of
path distances on a surface so in
general if you have a subset of a
Euclidean space everything is gonna be
in a finite dimensional weak immune
space you can define the intrinsic
distance that essentially it inherits
from the ambient space as being the
length of a shortest one lips curve I
guess continues curve that belongs to
the set that's important and that links
the two points of interest we're gonna
call it G so G of X I X so G of X X
prime is the intrinsic distance on s
between X and X prime okay so our our
disposal we have a sample iid from from
s so actually got a ID it can be iid bit
doesn't have to be this is just a habit
time
so just a sample of size n from s as you
see our results are non probabilistic
and we just assume like it's compact and
connected and then the goal is to
estimate G of X I XJ for all pairs and
so what we got to do is we're going to
form so here we're given the the points
so we do as in manifold learning and
what I so map does in factories we're
gonna form the neighborhood graph with
quality V T radius little R and then now
Delta of X X prime is going to denote
the graph distance between X and X prime
in that graph okay now this step seven
plays the same role as it did before
it's defined a bit differently now
so it's actually quantifies how dense
this sample is in s okay so we take any
point X in s and you look at the minimum
distance to one of the sample points
maximize that over all points in s and
you get tips on okay okay so this was
also this result here this upper bound
which is with the same as before but we
had to square and now it's on the
surface so this this is more general
before was in the union case is it
essentially has the same flavor so the
the other band he is always true but
sorry that's not true now but so I know
so so first this upper bound which is
relatively easy to get you get that the
graph distance between X X and X prime
is bound by well the did sick distance
between X and X Prime so sometimes
called geodesics is a bit of misnomer
but on s times the factors actually 1
plus ur an error in epsilon over R okay
this was known and was derived by the
people at designed as a map a while back
okay and so for an upper bound we need
some additional
conditions on s so som very consumptions
here and then that this is the main one
but the source pass on on s have
curvature at most kappa so it really is
their result we revisit we revisited the
result and sure could be derived from
much older results in the robotics
literature that was kind of our
contribution here that there is a
quantity that depends on the underlying
surface that can be essentially tied to
so-called reach of that surface and so
the surface is a manifold we are
boundary then
you know it doesn't simply if I think
okay I can save it more offline but
anyways it's not super complicated I
just don't want to find out and okay
and then so if the radius of community
is below this feature geometric feature
less and it's also just small compared
to one over the curvature one over the
curvature is maximum radius of turning
radius
so the minimum turning radius of maximum
turning radius minimum Tony reduce over
a very short data mask yes so but this
is so one over Kappa is the radius of
the smallest radius turning radius of a
curve on s sorry so then we have this
upper bound so before we had the lower
bound so the graph distance is here and
the interesting distance is on the right
hand side and he is reversed so the
increasing distance on the left hand
side then and the gratest on the right
hand side and before this was trivial
and you clean case so meaning that this
was the iniquity in the nucleus and here
because of the curvature is not trivial
anymore this an error of order R square
here and I think I'm missing a Kappa I
think it should be about me missing
something here sorry I said like a c0
was Universal but luckily might be a
Kappa R square my
yeah pause there's something number okay
so my main contribution there yeah so we
also show that not only dead battery so
this is approximately the distances but
you can also approximate the actual
paths so shortest paths in the graphs
correspond to shortest paths on the
surface and the main focus in the paper
is on curvature constrained shortest
paths and their distances so this can be
seen as a regularization of just
shortest paths which come with no
constraint really so this one so let's
define first a continuous quantity which
is the Kappa curvature constraint
intrinsic semi-decent from s so if you
have xx prime on s you look at the
shorts curve between X and X Prime on
the surface with that has curvature
point Y is bounded by Kappa so same as
before but you add the constraint that
the curve cannot have corners in
particular but it cannot curve too much
and our hope is to do the same so what
we did and so so far is that we
approximated the shortest path on
surface with the shortest paths on the
graph which are embedded as polygons
lines ok and we will want to do 17 years
so what we need is a notion of curvature
for polygon polygonal lines ok so this
is the one we worked with so let me just
explain so if you have so this is a
piece of curvature of a new polygon line
which is going to be an example of the
path that you're gonna use to
approximate a continuous curve so I am
sorry so a solid spot on s1 in the graph
is going to look like this once it's
embedded so we want to define a
curvature in particular the apexes right
so let's say this one middle how do you
define the curvature there so you look
at the neighboring corners I guess or
FX's vertices
and and then you look so this three
points define a circle that goes through
them and then you look at the inverse
you take the inverse of the radius of
that circle and that's the curvature at
that point always right when you have
three points so they find a plane but
the but the polygon line may not be the
whole thing now but you only look at
Triplets of points okay so there are
other notions of the discrete curvature
this was kind of new to us but yeah all
the notions of curvature in the
literature apparently but they're mostly
based on angle which is not something
that we can use but this one we can use
in particular has this nice consistency
result that says that if you have a
curve that's a continuous curve that has
just continued smooth curve that's a
twice differentiable then if you fix a
point on the curve and approach it on
both sides and and it's a new track the
the curvature defined by the triangle
there then it converges to the curvature
of that curve at that point okay so it
has that nice it's sort of a minimum we
can you want something else this is
quite Elementary to prove but I know we
wanted this so this has it and this was
much harder to prove but somehow we
managed is not very long proof but it
was somehow very anyway so if in fact
you have something a bit stronger so
this is this one is serve a synthetic
and we needed something like this for a
mini result which I'm gonna present in
two minutes so this one says that
so same setting you have a curve a
simple curve with the final curvature in
fact bounded by Kappa point-wise and if
you take three points on the curve the
same setting the point in middle is why
if the extreme points are close enough
to each other because they're far apart
anything goes right because then the
curve can do all the things even if it
doesn't self intersect it can be and
when I close then it's you know this
depends on cap PI doesn't go to zero as
opposed to the other one then the
curvature at Y defined by X and Z around
it is bound by Kappa so ask you tonight
so man in fact it was crucial to prove a
main result and this one was non-trivial
at least for us okay so for technical
reasons we worked with an annus graph
where in sub so the the graph typically
is defined well the one I define before
was the our ball neighborhood graph so
you connect two points if there are win
distance R but here we actually remove
some sort we do some sort of
regularization when we remove the inner
ball of radius R over four so we don't
connect points if there are at the
distance our before or closer okay so
does if you take the our board
neighborhood graph and regularize it by
removing the very short edges okay now
okay so now we define the notion of
curvature for polygonal lines we can
talk about the length of the shortest
paths in the graph now with curvature
bound by Kappa that's what we do so now
there's an upper bound and lower bound
so the upper bounds on the graph
distance is essentially the same as
before
okay this was the four here as opposed
to six but the only difference and
there's also constrained on epsilon over
R and there was no constraint a type for
before but this was for the upper bound
the other day of the bound but now there
is one so selective or constraint on my
turn over R its general again is the
quantifies how dense the sample is on
the surface R is the radius of
connectivity so external R has to be
small Kappa which is this constraint on
on the curves the shortest curves on s
he has to be small so R has to be small
compared to 1 over Kappa and oh I messed
this up sorry so this
to be so which one is kept up trying
this should be kept up right sorry about
that
so if you increase Kappa a little bit so
you have Kappa plus something that's
going to be small if those conditions
are satisfied
okay so cut up Kappa / nice kappa plus
something small then the graph distance
is constrained with the curvature being
at most Kappa prime are bounded by the
corresponding distances on s the
constraint to have curvature at most
Kappa I think we skip a little bit to
satisfy a similar inequality that we
don't have yeah so we have we need a
little bit of leeway so the hard result
was for us the other ones oh yeah did
you know under some Samaritan mild
conditions if you willing to assume that
the underlying set is a sub manifold
then c2 so manifold then it's true that
there's a number Kappa said that the
shortest paths are have curvature at
most cap and so I'm saying here the
actually subtlety is when the the set is
a sub manifold but with the boundary
then there's something that are actually
non-trivial and it wasn't our work but
we looked at the literature in actually
there the the setting is actually
surprisingly complicated
so here's corresponding upper bound this
this was this this is the main result in
particular paper it wasn't written for
us so we have essentially a matching
upper bound in a strong sense in that
the unconstrained pattern that annulus
graph okay that our surest between two
you know endpoints we actually show that
they already without constraint then
actually by themselves satisfy a
constraint or curvature
okay so the the unconstrained shortest
paths in the analyst graph satisfy
constrain of culture that's actually
close to the curvature on the continuous
side of things so close to the kaepa
that but bounds the curvature of no
paths on the surface so this is so if
again R is small and an epsilon over R
squared now is small it's a bit of a
stronger assumption then the source
paths on the graph we had constrained
them actually already have a constraint
on the curvature satisfy constant
curvature then the curvature is a Mudcat
a prime where Kappa prime is something
like Kappa plus something small actually
it's even stronger like we won't touch
down over ours cubes should be smaller
than the constant the constraints are
stronger but we have in exchange we have
a strong upper bound in that way I have
minutes for the remaining but try to
make sense of the pointman and at least
motivate you enough to go see the paper
if you want okay so this one is still on
estimating you can't distances been now
based on an adjacency matrix so you have
you still have the connectivity
information but we don't have the
weights on the edges that's gone no okay
and it goes as follows
this has we're not the first ones to
consider this there's some literature on
the topic and so I'll give some points
in the next slide but here's the setting
so you have an adjacency matrix but this
I really mean the weights are either 0 1
ok 1 if there's an edge at 0 the wescam
and we still have another graph to be
undirected we as we proposed the
existence of a configuration of points
in some european space that changed i
mentioned to be v here for some reason
but and now the Protea to see an edge
between I and J is a function of the
distance between X I and X J the X's are
unknown we only have their justice image
with no weights
in fact we also have seen the link
function is unknown well the goal is the
same we still want to estimate the
yueqin distances between the underlying
points and they're sometimes called
latent positions
yes this is a relatively well known
paper in the area and there's no work by
Kerry peonies group and in every cave
almost Bergen and her group I'll have
that to mention anyway and so you know
might be surprised I actually you can do
something we can do something there are
some restrictions but you can do quite a
bit so our estimator is still based on
so our goal again is to estimate the the
distance between the the latent
positions and our estimate is still
based on the graph distances I'm gonna
call them as I did before Delta that
digests the graphed distance between I
and J but now the weights are the zero
one right so essentially the the
distance here between I and J is the
number of links it takes to join I and J
in this graph and okay so if this link
function is this one here so it's one if
you know below are and zero otherwise
then we just put an R in front okay now
if our I select five could be unknown
right but it's imagine that Phi is
really under this form that our is
unknown well it's gone forever so I just
I'm gonna I'm gonna estimate up to a
scaling okay so so in a sense I can
assume that thank you in a sense I can
assume that R is is known because of
that okay because if it's unknown
essentially I have a choice of the best
R and the results is up to scaling which
is lost forever okay so that's our
estimate is still the are the set of
graph distances scale and we get a
similar ban as we had before it's also
pretty short proof under similar
conditions very similar proof very
similar arguments and in fact there's a
matching lower bound
so it's essentially the best you can
hope for at least under insert minimax
sense so it's possible in general maybe
a bit better but at least in the worst
case sense that's the best you can hope
for so this is for the case where Phi is
this okay I think I'm going to have time
to stay the the main result but here's
some very simple numerix those are the
actual latent positions this those are
recovered with this particular are
recovered this particular recover bits
particular are so you can do no using
what I just said that so you complete
the dis the distance matrix and then
apply classical scaling that's
essentially what ISO map does and and we
recover the points so this is a proof of
concept now the method if you saw the
the condition is a central one was that
the points are dense in their convex
Hall right so in the method requires
convexity and in fact if those are the
latent positions this is what you
recover so same same limitations as I so
map of course so without doing quite as
a map because here we don't have the
weights great but here's the marginal
case that we have in our paper and then
we had something else also but so now
Phi is unknown for us but we do assume
something so it goes it becomes 0 at R
but before it so it has some sort of
decay toward zero at R this is dictated
but alpha so alpha equals zero if
there's a jump discontinuity at R and
then we are almost the same setting as
before not quite and we're able to
recover the points so the distances but
now there's a rate that depends on on
our files well here and we can extend
this to a particular setting that's of
that was of particular interest to arica
votes for who was the main person in
recent years to push those problems and
we also we looked at the situation where
the adjacency matrix is not on our ball
graph on the underlying point set we're
on a cane years neighbor graph and the
situation is a bit different at the same
time is also similar when we are able to
be able to deal with that this is what
this whole thing happens then like this
those are the latent positions and when
you recover things you see that
something odd that happens right and the
reason is that the edges form some form
like as if like a high street for you a
freeway so the this is for the K nearest
neighbor graph and so between two points
that are towards the middle of the
rectangle things are ok but if the
points are far away from each other then
it pays off to actually go and boundary
I don't have time to explain what they
come ask me it's not hard to figure out
actually right so there's more in the
rate papers in there stop here thank you
questions how important is the sample
condition like I'm guessing I find this
but there must be something about friend
you are ball you have sufficient number
of points yeah
so you remember this condition steps and
over are being small that's exactly
that's the condition of being danced in
each ball of radius R so all the results
proceeded on if you saw it or not but
although all the results essentially had
epsilon over are being small and that's
essentially what you were I think you
know be out the Debian space no okay for
the
with minimal but in the second part when
we look at the curvature constraint
paths valves okay so there are didn't
talk really necessary on on using that
for embedding you can but I will just
like a just estimate those distances and
they're only the surface the curve I'm
not sure by the curvature part but what
doesn't turn to account what enters the
equation has to do with the the
intrinsic dimension is the density of
the points so we assume that the points
are dense enough and this can only be
achieved really realistically if if the
if the surface is of law in three
dimension yeah the NBN dimension doesn't
come in where do you see the fact that
you need the number of samples
exponentially in the intrinsic dimension
or so yeah so so isn't it in the epsilon
so epsilon like when you do like as
usual priority a poetic bounds right
that sign is going to be of the order of
log n over N to power 1 over D where
it's rule D like the dimension of the
underlying surface
yeah there's no escaping that yeah
so embedding irrigate by solving the EDM
very difference of the embedding
education is enough our map is a way of
solving idiom even put in the distance
that you're missing you just input for
them like use the graph distances let's
light them up well the that part of as a
map in the second part is a map is you
do you you apply a classical scaling to
get an embedding box by the metric
distances so we don't that's that's
laplacian again Maps I think what you
described now is the laplacian again
maps don't solve that wander directly I
sum up this but la pasion agamas they
don't directly solve the EDM problem we
can talk about more offline
okay there is not a professional